[Music]
foreign
cancellation as you know is like an
onion partly because it is acidic and
obnoxious but also because it has layers
sometimes a person is initially canceled
for one reason but when we look closer
we see whole new reasons to cancel them
and that brings us to this viral video
of a black man at a restaurant in
Georgia
accusing a white man of racism for
telling him the black man to turn his
phone down apparently this alleged
racism victim was playing something
loudly on his phone at a restaurant but
the bad guy is the other Patron who
asked him to lower the volume a bit uh
here it is watch
racism is still real in Georgia I can't
believe Bob tried me like that
[Music]
what was it what was it that you was
asked giving before you interrupted me
with my dinner
because I turned it all the way down for
you
okay but what was it that you was asking
me
is there a reason why you would ask me
to turn my phone down when there's a
band playing music that I don't give up
about hearing
do you think it's appropriate for you to
ask me a 33 year old a black man
to me
my hand should be shaking
now so many questions immediately
present themselves but the first and
most important one is why this man is
using his knife upside down he's holding
it by the blade and moving the food
around on his plate with the handle
that's the reason enough to kick him out
of the restaurant and ban him from ever
eating food in public ever again I'm
also wondering what other
basic motor skills
you know is he yet to master does he
brush his teeth by jabbing himself in
the eye with the toothbrush does he put
on his pants by I don't know eating them
how do you get to the age of 33 without
ever learning how to use eating utensils
I was going to ask if he knows how to
tie his shoes but I think we can assume
that they're probably velcro but let's
not get hung up on these details as I
said this is a cancellation onion and we
have only seen the first layer the next
layer is the most obvious one
here is yet another person who has been
conditioned to view everything through
the lens of victimhood and in this guy's
mind the only reason why anyone would
ask him to turn his phone down is
because they're racist
this kind of conditioning for many
people in modern society has become as
deeply ingrained and in many ways has
supplanted I think what psychologists
have called agency detection okay and
I'm going to take a little detour here
so stay with me but
agency detection is supposed to be an
instinct or inclination developed in all
sentient beings including humans to
assume that there is conscious agency
behind things that we observe around us
even when there isn't one so uh for
example
classic example when you hear the
floorboards creaking at night if you're
sleeping in an old house or something
and you assume that there's an Ax
Murderer out in the hallway about to
kill you that is agency detection
there's no Ax Murderer unless there
actually is an Ax Murderer I mean there
could be but if there isn't uh you
invented the story of a conscious and
usually nefarious agent who who is who's
caused an event to happen that was
really just the house you know settling
and making sounds the kind of sounds
that houses make some psychologists have
extended this idea out they've come up
with a theory called hyperactive agency
detection which is when someone is
constantly and falsely attributing
agency where there isn't any any at all
as you might expect this theory has been
used erroneously and absurdly to explain
away the development of religion in fact
that's why I think that's that's why
they came up with this as a way of
explaining the quote-unquote evolution
of religion anyway here's my point
um I would like to borrow from this
concept and coin a new term
hyperactive racism detection a person
with this mental Affliction is prone to
detect racism in every negative
experience he hears the floorboards
creaking at night and assumes it's not
only an Ax Murderer but a racist Ax
Murderer and if you tell them that there
is no Ax Murderer that it's just a house
settling then he'll insist that the
house is racist every bad thing is
racist no other explanation is even
entertained
the only thing that isn't racist in the
mind of the person suffering from hrd is
the person himself everyone else's
actions can be explained by racism but
never his own and this is in spite of
the fact that he is almost always the
most racist person in the room and very
often the only racist person in the room
the person with hyperactive racism
detection can detect racism everywhere
except in the places where it actually
is like in his own heart for example
with everything going on in the world
sometimes you just need a break from it
all choose to strengthen your faith
despite this broken world through prayer
meditation and fasting today hallow
helps me maintain a daily prayer routine
and it gives me a break from the
craziness around me you can download the
app for free at hello.com Matt Walsh you
can set prayer reminders you can track
your progress along the way if you're
not sure where to start check out father
Mike schmitz's Bible in a year podcast
available on the Hallow app for brief
daily Bible readings and Reflections or
you can pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel and even some world-class
athletes with Halo you can customize a
personal prayer plan that works for you
listen anywhere you're you are with a
downloadable offline sessions there's no
better time to stay rooted in your faith
and values get an exclusive three-month
free trial at hollow.com Matt Walsh
that's hello.com Matt Walsh today in an
alternate universe I'm you know there
might be psychologists there would be
psychologists writing papers about
hyperactive racism detection probably
prescribe driving drugs to fix it I'm
not really in favor of the
medicalization of every human character
flaw so I wouldn't actually want that to
happen but it is an interesting thought
anyway
but there's there's another layer
underneath this one
um this man is canceled because of how
he holds his eating utensils and he's
canceled because he's obsessed with
fighting racism everywhere he's also
canceled because he was playing
something on his phone loudly in public
this is the most egregious offense of
all by far somehow even worse than
holding your knife upside down I mean at
least this guy's like the only human on
the face of the Earth who uses his knife
like that but he's certainly not even
close to the only person who uses his
phone like that this has become an
epidemic okay I mean I see this
everywhere everywhere I go there are
people on speaker phone yeah FaceTime
um I was just at the airport the other
day and there was someone standing next
to me on FaceTime having a conversation
with some the person we could all hear
it
people do people are listening to music
they're playing videos all out in the
open for everyone to hear
so I want to make this very clear okay
this is the rule
I should never have to hear any sound
that your phone makes
I never want to hear any sound that it
makes it's actually
I have this rule for phones and for dogs
those two I don't want I never want to
hear you can have it that's fine I don't
want to hear any sounds from it ever
there is zero tolerance for any sounds
being emitted from your dog or a phone
if I'm if I'm anywhere in here shot
um I don't want to hear the
conversations you're having on your
phone I don't want to hear the crappy
music you're listening to on your phone
I don't want to hear the videos you're
watching on your phone unless you're
watching one of my videos in which case
exceptions can be made God made earbuds
for a reason and if you don't have
earbuds that's your problem use
subtitles I don't know I don't care just
as long as I never have to hear any
sounds emitting from that little box you
carry around in your pocket or better
yet if you're sitting at a restaurant
and um you're alone nothing wrong with
that by the way I'm a big proponent of
you know eating a lot of restaurant can
be very therapeutic
um but if you find yourself in that
situation
and you don't have earphones
and there's there's no way to listen to
something or watch something on your
phone without being a Monumental jerk to
everyone around you
well have you considered the possibility
that you don't need to be on your phone
at all
have you thought about just
sitting there have you considered
sitting there and eating
and not doing anything else but those
two things
like this is something I mean
I think for a lot of people in modern
society they've never done this have you
ever just sat somewhere and all you're
doing is sitting you're not doing
anything you're not looking at anything
you're not you're not listening to
anything you're just sitting
this is
you know a lot of people in modern side
I can't believe this but this was like a
normal
occurrence for people
all throughout human history up until
right now
there would be many occasions where
you're just sort of like
sitting somewhere and you're not you're
not doing anything else
and so then you're thinking
and that's that's the benefit you can
actually develop your own thoughts
so I would suggest that maybe try not
injecting noises and images and content
into your skull every second of every
day have you considered just allowing
yourself to be with your own thoughts
for maybe
three minutes at a time to start
I suppose you can't be with your
thoughts until you develop the ability
to have thoughts but you can't do that
unless you take a break from your phone
who knows
you might even become smart enough to
properly use a knife Anything is
Possible
but for now the guy in that video is
canceled and I'll do it for the show
today talk to you tomorrow have a great
day Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]